next week coming to you from c2e2 see
you then
[Music]
well here we are at Chicago comics and
Entertainment Expo
you can just say CTD - fun fact there
are over 80,000 attendees last year hard
facts
alright girls not a girl who's read a
book if we're gonna get a good seat at
the next panel
[Music]
my name is Walter benezia for months I
was trapped in the evil Dynel Rob's dial
dimension a place where I was duplicated
dozens of times eventually I managed to
escape but now died rob is sending his
army to take me back with the help of my
friends he fight them off and hoped to
ultimately take down this deranged
dinosaur the more we countdown the
weaker he gets this is top-5
there are some amazing costumes here
yeah did you see that Khaleesi we passed
back in the lobby no that was just some
naked guy named Daniel run through
convention huh still better than back
nipples not good points that was
definitely one of the worst superhero
movie guests but there's so many Oh
number 5 Green Lantern in Green Lantern
the highly anticipated live-action Green
Lantern was met with debate after
releasing their first trailer a lot of
viewers noted that although a trailer
wasn't necessarily indicative at the
final product Hal Jordans full CGI
costume looked less than perfect the
decision was made for better or worse in
hopes that digital effects could create
a material that transcends what's
physically capable by practical effects
the aim was to show the suit as a
construct of the power ring making every
detail rich and conducive to the
fictional aerodynamics but what it felt
was artificial everything draws your
eyes to his existence rather than just
existing his mask isn't actually sitting
on his face it's a lie the muscle
details make it feel as if his muscular
system was sitting on the outside of his
body even his feet are super disturbing
remember when toe shoes were a thing
this is somehow worse Ryan Reynolds
didn't know what the final result would
look like since he spent the majority of
filming in a motion capture suit but I
have a feeling we'll be seeing him back
on this list momentarily
number four Aries in Wonder Woman as
much as I loved Wonder Woman it's
obviously not a perfect movie one of my
biggest complaints with it was the main
villain Ares the worst thing about his
design is the awful CGI this would be
something that I could excuse if this
movie were made years ago but it had no
right being as bad as it was in a
big-budget Hollywood movie in 2017 the
graphics looked worse than a video game
in fact I like the way Ares looks more
in injustice than this movie the
lighting is off his movements aren't
fluid and awkward at times it was so
jarring it took me out of the moment
outside of the shockingly unfinished
looking CGI one of the strangest choices
for this costume was that they kept the
mustache before he transformed into Ares
Sir Patrick was a British diplomat with
his bushy albeit time appropriate
mustache it doesn't make sense for the
character to keep this mustache after
his transformation into the God of War
it makes him look like a joke could he
not have shaved the mustache for those
scenes I guess I would rather him keep
the mustache than pole Justice League
though lastly the design in and of
itself was not fitting for a god the
silhouette the costume created look more
like a generic minion rather than the
God of War himself it was rounded not
strong the distressed metal that he
called up to create the armor made him
look even more tired and basic what a
lackluster and disappointing ending to
an otherwise great movie
[Music]
number three the Green Goblin in the
amazing spider-man 2 a lot of people
hate Norman Osborn's Green Goblin
costume from 2002 spider-man it's not
like the comic they say looks like a
Power Ranger they say I for one resent
that although it does suck for the
purists out there that they had a much
more comic accurate prototype made and
didn't use it at all
by the time spider-man 3 came around we
all thought we are going to have another
shot at getting the Green Goblin costume
right however what Harry Osborn became
in that movie wasn't even the Green
Goblin credited as the new Goblin
Harry's look was more evil snowboarder
than haunting nemesis while that was a
disappointment the worst was yet to come
most recently in 2014's amazing
spider-man 2 Dane DeHaan was cast as
Harry Osborn and set to play the actual
Green Goblin as well after his great
performance in 2012's Chronicle I
thought Dane was a great choice to play
the emotionally unstable frenemy of
Peter Parker however through a
convoluted backstory about a genetic
disease in a very awkward script his
performance didn't nearly live up to the
potential it had when he transforms into
the Green Goblin towards the end of the
film we got something he didn't look
like the Green Goblin but sure was
something I can't blame Dane for this
he's trying to be menacing he really is
I don't know who could come off as
intimidating and an outfit and makeup
like that he's got a boring little
battle suit they couldn't be more
generic and they made his face look like
he's been trippin on bath salts for
three weeks they even gave him a little
flippy do in the back of his head why is
that there is this the Green Goblin or
rejected fast food mascot
I know Dane I'm sorry so sorry
number two Catwoman in Catwoman we've
covered Catwoman in a previous top-five
episode but Halle Berry's costume was
worth a spot on this list after being
transformed from shy graphics designer
into femme fatale Catwoman the first cat
suit patients Don's is surprisingly
better than the final result though
there's a weird explanation as to how
she got it as a gift for friends that
were surprisingly invested in her love
life it's still more of an explanation
than we got for where this came from
this is barely an excuse for a top
there's no back and the push-up bra is
hardly attached at her bust oh but thank
goodness for those belts holstering it
down across her torso how would one
steal diamonds in that I would
constantly be occupied thinking
something would fall out have you ever
worn jeans with some fashionable
distressing over the thighs you sit down
and your thighs pour over the little
holes
imagine that in leather and all the way
around your butt it's clearly not based
on any source material which in and out
of itself is not a sin but the final
product has to make the deviation worth
it
[Music]
and the number one worst superhero movie
costume is Deadpool in x-men origins
Wolverine yep
Ryan Reynolds reappears and tops our
list for starters this movie seems
genuinely confused about what made
Deadpool so intriguing this
bastardization makes his special
abilities and amalgamation of other
mutants like teleporting optic blasts
and extending metal through his arms
wait Wilson is known for breaking the
fourth ball and his bad habit of telling
jokes at inappropriate times his earlier
appearance in the film gets pretty close
okay
people are dead you didn't have that
mouth on you Wade
he's a perfect soldier then they swerve
left abandoning his distinct red and
black suit for a scar free torso with
geometric tattoos and mermaid skin face
but most importantly Deadpool is known
as the mark with the mouth the movie
even acknowledges this he's rude is
crude he's got super healing dude and
you go and remove his mouth unforgivable
at least now we can rest in the
knowledge that Deadpool has finally been
done justice and Ryan Reynolds has now
led one of the most successful comic
adaptations of all time
it is I the tower of power the
skyscraper of turn Lord yes it is a
never be able to grow to the size of a
small building
Oh human building human building I
thought this was a West world
[Music]
[Applause]
you